[Música]
momento de hablar de salud en directo
América y le doy la bienvenida a mar
Romero sala mar bienvenida Gracias
Andrés mar dedicamos la sección de hoy a
hablar de la importancia de los baños
públicos sí Andrés una importancia para
la calidad de vida para la salud y te
aseguro que después de que escuches lo
que vamos a decir hoy porque al menos a
mí me pasa haciendo la investigación
vamos a cambiar cómo pensamos en los
baños porque suele ser algo que no le
damos nada de importancia pero tiene un
impacto muy grande en nuestra vida Yo
creo que todos nos podemos sentir
identificados con por ejemplo necesitar
un baño en el espacio público y tener
que depender de los baños de
establecimientos privados como los de la
hostelería no bares restaurantes o
incluso los de los centros comerciales y
todas las dificultades la logística que
eso entraña hay personas para quien Esto
no es una es una situación ocasional
sino que es una experiencia cotidiana
del día a día hablamos por ejemplo de
los enfermos de pues enfermedades de
inflamación intestinal como la co la
enfermedad de crohn personas con
enfermedades urinarias personas que
toman medicación que sea altamente
diurética con lo que necesiten un baño
con frecuencia no en general un término
que acuñado el equipo de investigadores
españoles que están estudiando estas
experiencias son las personas que
dependen de baños públicos Vamos a
repasar los datos de alguno de estos
estudios que se han publicado vemos que
en un cuestionario desarrollado por
estos investigadores de la universidad
Camilo José cela las personas
dependientes de un baño público tienen
una experiencia más negativa altamente
más negativa que las personas que no son
dependientes de años de años públicos a
la hora de usar precisamente los aseos y
que usando en la escala de la OMS de
satisfacción vital vemos Que puntúan
peor también en la calidad de su salud
física en la calidad psicológica Y en
este término amplio que se llama
satisfacción vital no hay menos
satisfacción vital general en las
personas dependientes de baños públicos
que las personas que no son dependientes
en variabilidad de un 10% es decir la
falta de euro acceso a baño público
puede explicar un 10% menos de calidad
de vida para este tipo de personas y en
qué se traduce menos satisfacción vital
claro esa misma pregunta no para
comprenderlo mejor se la hicimos a guido
corradi que es profesor de la
Universidad de José Camilo José cela
perdón y autor de estas investigaciones
escuchemos
que tengas que cambiar tus planes por
ejemplo para a la hora de
cambiar tus planes porque sabes que no
hay un baño Vale pues también la falta
de un baño es una experiencia negativa
con un baño público y esto en las
entrevistas solía salir mucho de
personas que me decían mira que yo no
voy al parque o sea yo no voy a esta a
esta zona el médico me dice que haga
ejercicio y salga a caminar lo que yo no
puedo salir a caminar porque el parque
la zona verde la única casa no tiene
baños claro este es solo un ejemplo no
pero hay algo muy importante que nos
decía también Y es que al final todos un
momento u otro vamos a ser dependientes
de baños públicos o solo pensando por
ejemplo en los niños o las personas
mayores que en general también suelen
tener una dependencia mayor y al final
el tabú que rodea este tema la vergüenza
que se asocia a este tema carga a todo
el mundo tanto a los dependientes de
baños públicos como los que a la larga
no escuchemos al principio nos fijamos
en personas que tienen dependencia no y
hay unos artículos habla sobre cómo
incrementa la vergüenza hacia la propia
enfermedad no que esto luego está
relacionado con que tengas menos te
sientas menos capaz de pedir ayuda
de Buscar
de buscar la ayuda en otras personas
etcétera sino que esta carga también
ocurre en personas que no son
dependientes
o qué vamos a decir que no son
dependientes de largo plazo porque
dependiente baño público todo el mundo
en algún momento lo va a hacer Mari por
supuesto la falta de acceso a baños
públicos tiene impactos sobre la salud
Cuáles son estos Sí bueno primero está
justo lo que estaba mencionando Corral y
no que es este tema de la vergüenza que
hace que la persona entonces con una
enfermedad que hace que necesite el baño
se sienta tenga una peor relación con su
propia enfermedad entonces pídame nos
ayuda eso a medio largo plazo tiene
consecuencias sobre la salud pero luego
también sabemos que es que aguantar las
ganas de ir al baño o limitar el uso del
baño no es bueno para todo el mundo hay
un estudio que se hizo en mujeres porque
de hecho las mujeres están afectadas
desproporcionadamente por este tema
porque suele ser las personas o mujeres
o personas con vagina suelen ser todavía
más incómodo no el uso de baños públicos
y en las personas que limitan su uso de
baño público durante el día tienen por
ejemplo más síntomas de infección de
tracto urinario en general hablamos de
incontinencia hablamos de vejiga
hiperactiva por ejemplo que es la
necesidad repentina de orinar o
infecciones recurrentes incluso son más
amplias en las personas que limitan su
uso de baño públicos que en las personas
que no lo limitan esto pasa en las
mujeres como vemos pero también puede
suceder en profesiones que sea los que
sea difícil encontrar esos momentos por
ejemplo hablamos de médicos médicas
cajeros cajeras de supermercado y esta
falta al final de baños y este limitar
su uso golpea entonces más duramente
sobre todo a las profesiones Digamos
como menos calificadas o ocupadas en
general por personas de clases más
populares porque el acceso al baño
durante su trabajo es más difícil o
porque tienen que hacer recorridos más
largos de su casa a su trabajo y también
importante aquí destacar lo que sucede
con las personas trans no binarias queer
o disconformes con el género tradicional
de alguna forma que ven Pues el uso su
uso de los baños muy complejo
normalmente en el espacio público fuera
de su espacio de Confort doméstico no
entonces todas las personas se ven más
afectadas y las consecuencias sobre la
salud como vemos con el caso con los
ejemplos que estábamos viendo pues
pueden ser muy amplios ahora cuál sería
o cómo sería el baño público ideal sí
nos hacían una salvedad al hablar de
esto de que es difícil hablar de uno en
general porque de diferentes poblaciones
pueden tener diferentes necesidades y es
importante entonces escuchar a los
usuarios para comprender qué es lo que
se necesitan pero la investigación de
corral y el equipo pues daba unos ejes
no primero la intimidad algo tan simple
como tiene pestillo o no tiene pestillo
el baño público el higiene por supuesto
algo que hace mucho más fácil de usar el
baño y luego este eje que se llamaba la
usabilidad es decir algo también Tan
sencillo como si ese baño tiene papel o
tiene algún lugar donde colgar nuestras
cosas todas esas cosas hacen que estemos
más dispuestos a usar un baño público
que si no lo tienen y al final como nos
decía No no es pedir el cielo es hablar
de un tema de salud pública al que no
hemos conseguido darle relevancia
todavía pero que una mejora para los
grupos más afectados puede
Pues contrastar a todo el mundo afectar
a todo el mundo Esa era la conclusión
precisamente de guido corradio cualquier
mejora a un grupo vulnerados revierte
necesariamente
en mejoras para el grupo más normotípico
muchas veces mejorar la vida de otras
personas que sufren unas cargas más
unas cargas específicas suele mejorar la
bueno suele siempre mejora la vida de
las personas que
que no necesitan ese extra que no
necesitan esa adaptación Bueno ya con
todo este tema toda esta radiografía que
hicimos sobre la importancia de baños
públicos el llamado queda a los
gobiernos locales primero a construir
más baños públicos a los dueños de
establecimientos privados a ser más
solidarios también y por supuesto al
público a cuidar estos baños claro y
pensar eso que al final algo que afecta
a una población específica nos va a
ayudar a todos a tener mejor calidad de
vida mejores experiencias exactamente
mar Muchas gracias Feliz fin de semana
ya descansar la otra semana Entonces la
veo con más noticias nos vemos el lunes